salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux
vous avez vu mon écran depuis quelques
temps je teste le Dark mode
sombre en français rien de très original
vous êtes très nombreux à avoir adopté
ce nouveau mode d'affichage même Google
s'y est mis sur sa page d'accueil et
c'est aussi le mode d'affichage choisi
par défaut de la plupart des montres
connectés enfin nouveau pas tellement
puisqu'à l'origine les écrans étaient
noirs je m'en souviens alors pourquoi et
comment est-on passé d'une page noire à
une page blanche et vice versa on répond
à toutes ces questions avec un
spécialiste du sujet Michael de la
chaîne micode
[Musique]
je ne t'apprends rien si on remonte à la
naissance de l'écriture 3000 ans avant
notre ère jusqu'à l'invention de
l'imprimerie en 1450 on constate que les
hommes ont toujours écrit sur des fonds
clairs alors quand en 1977 les premiers
ordinateurs personnels avec écran
intégré propose des fonds d'écran tout
noir et ben c'est une petite révolution
les concepteurs veulent-ils
impressionner leurs copains avec un
style d'Arc de hacker c'est peu probable
car à l'époque les hackers ça n'existe
pas non la réalité est beaucoup plus
simple techniquement on ne savait pas
faire autrement en effet dans les années
1970 il n'est pas encore question
d’écran plat LCD 4K à 16 millions de
couleurs les écrans d'ordinateur sont
équipés de tube cathodique leur
fonctionnement est très simple un signal
électrique envoie un faisceau
d'électrons à haute vitesse sur un écran
phosphorescent lorsque le phosphore de
l'écran est frappé par un électron il
est excité et c'est ainsi qu'il produit
de la lumière pour des raisons de coûts
la couche phosphores les premiers écrans
cathodiques étaient vertes ce qui nous
donnait du texte vert sur un fond tout
noir ça rappelle sans doute de bons
souvenirs au plus anciens d'entre vous
le mode sombre est donc la norme et
faute d'autre chose personne ne songe à
100 plaindre mais l'évolution du
matériel va permettre enfin de fabriquer
des ordinateurs en mode clair il ne
tarde pas à envahir le marché signant au
passage la fin du Dark mode tous les
professionnels s'accordent à dire que le
mode clair est la meilleure option pour
le confort des utilisateurs c'est du
moins l'option la plus
ergonomique pour que les ordinateurs
personnels soient simples d'utilisation
on estime en effet qu'ils doivent imiter
les gestes du travail on crée des
dossiers pour classer les fichiers on
envoie des courriers électroniques on
invente même des corbeilles virtuels
pour se débarrasser de tout ce qui
encombre notre bureau selon cette
logique les fabricants estiment qu'il
faut aussi imiter le visuel du papier
des livres ou des journaux avec du texte
noir sur fond clair mais ce ne sont pas
les seules raisons qui expliquent
l'avènement des écran les fabricants
d'ordinateurs vont prendre en compte un
autre facteur l'anatomie de l'oeil
humain vous savez comment fonctionne
notre œil quand il y a beaucoup de
lumière la pupille c'est-à-dire le petit
orifice situé au centre de l'iris se
ferme pour éviter qu'il n'entre trop de
lumière et que l'on soit ébloui à
l'inverse quand il fait sombre elle
s'ouvre pour qu'il en pénètre
suffisamment la lumière atteint ensuite
la rétine sur laquelle se forme l'image
le problème c'est que dans l'obscurité
nos pupilles ne savent pas très bien
comment réagir quand survient un éclat
de lumière et nous avons alors du mal à
faire la mise au point c'est ce qui se
passe vous l'avez sûrement remarqué
quand on fixe une étoile dans un ciel
noir ce n'est pas très net il y a un
halo autour de l'étoile le même
phénomène se produit lorsqu'on lit sur
un écran noir les lettres blanches
réfléchissent et disperse la lumière sur
les lettres environnantes et forme alors
un minuscule halo lumineux sur
l'ensemble du texte de fait la lecture
est plus floue et moins agréable pour
mesurer la gêne que peut causer le mode
sombre des chercheurs ont réalisé une
expérience en 2013 ils ont demandé à
deux groupes distincts d'effectuer des
exercices d'acuité visuelle l'un avec
comme support un écran sombre l'autre un
écran clair on allait enfin pouvoir
trancher la question le mode sombre
est-il plus adapté ou moins adapté à la
lecture la réponse est très claire le
Dark mode c'est moins bien on a en effet
observé des performances
significativement meilleur avec le mode
clair notamment pour ce qui concerne la
rapidité de lecture en autre plus les
caractères sont petits en taille plus le
mode clair se distingue par de meilleurs
résultats si je récapitule ça fait des
années que l'informatique utilise des
écrans à fond clair et c'est à juste
titre il nous facilite les choses et
pourtant voilà que Google Apple et
quelques autres ne propose aujourd'hui
des écrans en mode sombre
quelle mouche a donc piqué les géants de
l'informatique il s'agit à coup sûr d'un
effet de mode popularisé par certaines
applications comme discord ou Spotify
qui utilise un mode sombre par défaut le
noir renverrait aussi à l'imaginer du
luxe la tentation de sciences et donc
grande pour les stars d'Internet enfin
ils ont aussi sans doute cédé face à une
idée reçue qui a la vie dure le mode
sombre serait plus reposant pour nos
yeux on l'a vu c'est complètement faux
enfin c'est faux on vous a peut-être pas
encore tout dit tout n'est pas blanc ou
noir mon cher ami loin de là le mode
sombre présente en fait un gros avantage
sur le mode clair il aimait beaucoup
moins de lumière et donc beaucoup moins
de lumière bleue or la lumière bleue des
écrans vous en avez sûrement entendu
parler est assez préoccupante pour notre
santé notamment pour la qualité de notre
sommeil en effet elle fait croire au
cerveau qu'il fait encore jour ce qui
bloque la sécrétion de mélatonine
l'hormone du sommeil donc de ce point de
vue le mode sombre le soir est plutôt
recommandé tenez Netflix ou disney+
l'ont très bien compris en adoptant un
dark mode par défaut sur leur site web
les développeurs les traders raffolent
aussi du mode sombre mais pour une toute
autre raison il fait mieux ressortir les
couleurs que ce soit celle des
graphiques colorés comme sur l'Apple
watch du code informatique des courbes
de trading ou même tout simplement des
photos de vacances enfin et ce n'est pas
négligeable il permet de faire de
sérieux économies d'électricité un
appareil en mode sombre peut
théoriquement consommer 60% de moins que
le mode clair surtout depuis l'avènement
des écrans OLED sur les smartphones leur
fonctionnement est très simple
l'éclairage de chaque pixel est géré
indépendamment quand un pixel est noir
il s'éteint donc sur cette page en mode
sombre à peine un quart de l'écran et
effectivement allumé en pratique je
préfère vous prévenir vous ne gagnerez
pas 60% de batterie désolé mais pour un
site comme la page d'accueil de Google
qui est consultée par des millions de
personnes tous les jours les économies
seront quand même significatives à tel
point que pendant des années les
concurrents de Google ont utilisé cet
argument écologique pour vanter leurs
services face aux géants du Net qui
persistaient à garder sa page d'accueil
toute blanche au final je vous conseille
donc d'utiliser le mode clair la journée
et le mode sombre le soir et la nuit nos
téléphones sont toujours du capables de
faire à la bascule tout seul lorsque la
nuit tombe évidemment c'est aussi une
question de goût et de couleur vous
faites ce que vous voulez de toute façon
moi je suis à tenir mais la prochaine
fois si vous êtes en plein soleil et que
votre téléphone est difficilement
lisible en mode sombre faites le test
passez en mode claire vous allez être
surpris de la différence merci Mickaël
pour cette exposé brillant je me permets
une toute petite précision si vous êtes
victime d'affection comme la cataracte
ou la photophobie une très forte
sensibilité à la lumière dans ce cas
utiliser le mode sombre 24 heures sur 24
peut vous aider à réduire votre
exposition à la lumière et vous soulager
allez merci à toutes et à tous d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo jusqu'au bout c'est
le meilleur soutien que vous pouvez nous
apporter et puis si vous ne voyez pas où
j'ai bien abonnez-vous si ce n'est pas
déjà fait et si les nouvelles
technologies vous intéressent n'hésitez
pas à nous proposer des sujets en
commentaire on regardera ça de très près
avec Michael à très bientôt chers
epicurieuses et épicurieuse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]